it is the season debut of justin dunn
and he
got many a mariner fan excited by the
increased stuff we saw in spring
training
one out one on abreu at the plate
fair ball to seeger off his heels down
to france to first not in time
runner goes pitch on the way outside a
ball and no throw down to second base by
tom murphy
and it's second is abreu with a stolen
base
now the white sox have runners at first
and second with two outs
and here is designated hitter zach
collins 0-2
boy he goes around he got him done a
little fired up he gets out of
trouble in the first inning strands
appeared
dallas keiko had a magnificent year last
year in era below two not gonna strike
out a whole lot of people doesn't walk a
whole lot of people and he's not gonna
see
too many left-handers so they have a
base runner with nobody out
ty france had the mariners first
three-hit
game of the season last night
struck him out a sinker on the outer
half and france goes down
and the mariners have two on only one
out and the batter will be evan white
right back to gold level kykel on the
second
on the first not in time
kaneger into third
in the center hanging up robert is
sliding
and making the catch there was a lot of
ground
mariners strand two were scoreless
robert will lead off for the sox here in
the second in a scoreless tie
three and one robert tags this ball up
the left center field alleyway and here
comes the speed of louise robert
he's into second base and it is a
lead-off
two-base hit for luis
billy hamilton swears to bond murphy
[Applause]
back in a quick tag too i didn't think
there was going
to be a play on it they will challenge
it
you see something there i think so this
batting glove you can see the white of
his batting glove by the leg of the
umpire and it wasn't quite there
have a decision there it is how about
that flower power
it's got service same page nicely done
and that's the fourth walk given up by
justin dunn and we're only in the top of
the second and
so the sox have runners on at first and
second now with two outs
no score and that'll bring up lead off
better right fielder adam eaton another
2-2 from dunn
on the ground seeger what a play on the
second france has it
nicely started by the gold lover
hard hit and through the shift into
right field frank's making the turn
galloping into third cal sega two for
two
left on left is dallas here's an
opportunity
for evan white
soft chopper lamb
they get seeger at second ty
france scores the first run of this ball
game and the mariners
lead at one-nothing taylor trammell's
bottom four
one-nothing mariners
strike three change-up from keiko one
gone
crawford with two outs kaiko sure could
use a quick inning
lines and throws and a ground ball
madrigal picks it up and throws and
that's it
so it is a one two three fourth for
keiko we go to the fifth
it's still one nothing mariners billy
hamilton with a lead off walk
2-1 hamilton goes
and this is popped up to first base
hamilton slides around it
and gets back to the bag danny mendick
went upstairs to tomahawk a ball
it becomes a pop-up and one away well
it's a good thing that nobody called for
the rebound at first because
with marmalajos and dunn contesting that
one
finally secured by dunn no chance to get
hamilton
three walks to lodem and jose abreu who
has
two grand slams in the first six games
is raring to go here it comes on 1-2
shallow pop-up crawford right behind the
bag
two outs justin one more out away from
working out of a whole lot of trouble
here is jasmine grandall bases are
loaded with two outs of mariners hanging
on to a one-nothing lead here at the top
of the fifth
dunn misses outside and the sox have
tied the game
in a four walk fifth inning this has
been
a bizarre afternoon in seattle
and suddenly we're even at one eight
walks for done and a chance for zach
collins to do a little more damage
there's a swing and a ground ball into
that base hit
collins is gonna knock in a couple and
the white sox lead
three to one madrigal on his way to
second he's got a double
danny mendick a walk in an infield hop
out
3-2 coming danny spikes it into
left-center field and down
madrigal's coming home and danny mendic
they pitched him over and over again in
the bottom of the zone and he was
wise to the game on the final pitch of
the sequence
four to one and that is going to be it
for dallas kykel but the bases are
loaded for seattle in the sixth
opportunity a knocking for taylor
tremell
0 for two today
into right field for a base hit
marmalado scores taylor trammell
not waiting around jumps on that first
pitch
that brings the mariners within two one
out here in the sixth
and bring up j.p crawford here's the
one-two pitch
here he comes reaches out punches it
into the cap that's gonna work
marmo scores here comes murphy he held
up
making sure the ball didn't get caught
maniaca held him up at third so we go 90
feet
now the run scores it's 4-3 chicago base
is still loaded one out
and now you got mitch haniger the next
to hannigan
fly ball deep it up out to right center
robert eaton and eaton makes the catch
murphy coming home
mitch haniger a sac fly to right field
he has
tied this game in the sixth inning
looking for the lead with two outs bases
loaded
now let's see if seger can capitalize he
has two hits on the afternoon
to kyle pitch swung on and lifted to
left field down the line it's going to
get down
scoring his tremel scoring his crawford
motoring as france
getting the wave on he's going to score
kyle sieger with a basis clearing double
and the mariners have a 7-4 lead you'll
love
two out ribbish big spot another run out
there for marmo
payoff coming into right center field
seeger
put it on the jets pounding the bag at
third making the turn home make it eight
to four mariners
[Applause]
[Music]
faces loaded so things were looking up
and now
graveman has pitched himself into
mariners into a jam
right now he needs something from page
two on the menu how about a ground ball
double play get out of the inning
base is loaded tough hitter luis robert
crawford
a double stairs to get out of the jam
last hope for the white sox yasmani
grendal 2-2
that's a good way to end it the mariners
get the victory today against the
chicago white sox mike
8-4 our final score